[Music]
What's
YouTube?
I established the Sea Shepard
Conservation Society in 1977
as an organization to intervene against
uh poaching against illegal activities
on the high seas. So, we're really an
anti-poaching organization and we
intervene globally and we do so with
what I call aggressive nonviolence.
What is aggressive nonviolence? Well,
we're aggressive, but we never injure
anybody. And in our entire 40-year
experience, we've never caused a single
injury to any person at all. But we have
shut down numerous poaching operations
from, you know, over fishing, uh,
whailing, uh, shark killing, turtle
killing. Uh, we've shut these things
down through aggressive intervention,
but at the same time being very careful
not to injure anybody.
How do you imagine the the ocean's
future from your point of view? Will it
be better or on the contrary worse?
Well, the future of the ocean is what
we're seeing right now, which is a um an
escalating diminishment of biodiversity.
We've lost 90% of the fishes over the
last 100 years. We've had a 40%
diminishment in phytolankton population
since 1950. So, there's some very
serious situations that have been
happening as far as a diminishment of
biodiversity. The problem is is most
people are unaware of that. Uh by 2048,
according to Dr. Boris Worm of Dhausy
University and Dr. Daniel Paulie of the
University of British Columbia who are
the two foremost oceanographic fishery
scientists. Uh there won't be any
fishing industry in 19 in 2048 because
there won't be any fish. Uh there won't
be any coral reefs. Uh so what we're
looking at is a is an ecological
disaster within our oceans. And uh that
doesn't bode well for the future of
humanity because as I always say, if the
ocean dies, we die. We don't live on
this planet with a dead ocean. And as
the ocean is diminished, our ability to
survive is diminished. But at the same
time today it seems that despite your
fight the humanity does not measure the
impact of losing biodiversity in oceans.
So concretely when are things going to
change and how could it change?
For hundreds and of years now well for
millions of years the uh the ocean has
been the life support system of the of
the planet. If you look at the earth as
a as a spaceship which is traveling
through space which is what it is. Every
spaceship has a life support system and
it provides the food we eat. It
regulates the temperature, controls the
climate and it provides the uh air that
we breathe. And that life support system
is to be found in the ocean. And that
life support system is run by a crew. A
crew of uh on this planet which are are
all these various species that make it
work. We're not crew. We're passengers.
We're having a great time entertaining
ourselves. But what we're doing is
killing off the crew. the phytolankton
that produces the oxygen, the whales
that uh uh provide the nutrients for the
phytolanton, the u the inter
relationship with all the species that
keeps everything running and has kept
everything running for millions of
years. We're seriously compromising the
efficiency of that. What if you look at
it in terms of machinery that life
support system and that's a very serious
uh situation. 40% diminishment of
phytolankton population since 1950 is a
serious situation that really nobody's
aware of. uh phytolanin provides between
uh 50 and 70 or possibly even 80% of all
of the oxygen that we breathe. The rest
coming from trees and plants. And if you
remove phytolanton, which is now
seriously being depleted, then we simply
will not have oxygen to breathe. And uh
the relationship between phytolanton and
whales is that whales provide the
nutrients for the phytolanton iron and
nitrogen primarily uh through the feces
similar to horsemen on a providing
fertilizer on a farm. So the whalers the
whales are in fact the farmers of the
ocean but we don't you know we're not
intelligent enough to really understand
all of those interreationships and the
and the interdependence of all of those
species and uh as such we're depleting
that ability of the oceanic ecosystems
to sustain life on this planet.
I'm sure you heard about the cup 21 the
conference of parties in Paris. At the
end of the media event, the former
president of the cup, Lauren Fabuse,
talked about a historic agreement. Now
we're six months later. What is your
feeling about these agreements? And do
you think the conference pushed people
and companies to realize the emergency
of the situation?
Well, COP 21 was a nothing event. Uh
nothing came out of it. It was a great
opportunity for all the world leaders to
pat themselves on the back and do photo
opportunities about how they're going to
save the planet. but they didn't discuss
anything of uh of any relevance. Um I
presented a booklet on solutions to
climate change that nobody wants to hear
and they certainly didn't want to hear
it and they certainly didn't discuss it.
And the fact is that if we want to
protect uh this planet from the
consequences of climate change and one
we have to allow the ocean to repair
itself. That means we have to stop all
industrialized fishing operations. We
have to stop subsidies on industrialized
fishing operations. You know, it takes
time and unless we're willing to do
that, the oceans are going to die. Uh,
another solution to that is that we have
to switch to plant-based diets because
we're killing 65 billion animals every
year and that's not counting the ones
that we take out of the ocean. And uh
the animal husbandry industry
contributes more greenhouse gases to uh
the atmosphere than the entire
transportation industry and also
consumes more water, creates dead zones
and is one of the most serious causes of
pollution both in groundwater and in the
ocean. And uh but nobody really wants to
address those solutions. They want to
find um uh answers that are for you know
that are acceptable that don't don't
affect our lifestyle. And at the same
time, governments want to find uh
solutions through taxation. They figure
that this is a good opportunity to tax
everybody in order to bring that money.
But as I found on environmental taxes
throughout the world is that when
they're collected, they don't go towards
solving the problem. They basically go
to what governments usually spend their
money on, which is wasting it on
ridiculous things like defense or uh
subsidies or um or their own payrolls.
From your point of view, is France
involved on grain issues or completely
blind?
Well, France is no different than any
other country, which means that France,
like all these other countries, is doing
nothing to address the real uh problems.
Uh you know, there's a pretense that
there's things being done, but just on
the oceans, for example, France controls
uh the second largest maritime territory
on the planet. Uh the French Navy is in
a wonderful opportunity to enforce
illegal uh against illegal fishing
operations, but they don't do very much.
And I I've actually spoken to the
admiral of the French Navy, the about
this, and he agrees, but he said that
their hands are tied politically.
What is your feeling about Nicola? I
think Nikolai Lo is is certainly, you
know, he when he was putting together
the COP 21, I think he came to realize
that it wasn't going to uh it wasn't
going to achieve what he hoped it would
achieve. And I think he was quite
disappointed about this. Uh I think he's
probably the uh the only one is in sort
of a political position in France to
who's actually sincerely wants to find
an answer.
Your organization Sea Shepard suffering
some criticism. For instance, some
people pointed out your lack of
tolerance towards poor population
activities. For example, you made a
campaign in Larion to protect sharks and
in fact the local population was puzzled
because it was a question of dozen of
sharks while French vessel fish
thousands of tons of sharks every year
and there is no campaign there. So do
you accept and understand these
criticisms? Uh first on the first
question, uh we don't target uh anybody
who doesn't act illegally. So I don't
really care if people are rich or poor.
If they're breaking the law, we're going
to oppose them. But we're what we're
primarily doing is uh going against
large corporate fishing operations. I
mean, we're talking about multi-million
dollar corporations that are are are
literally looting the oceans. Right now,
we have one of our vessels working in
partnership with the government of
Gabong to stop um illegal fishing in
Japanese waters. Last week, we arrested
three Chinese vessels that were
operating that water illegally. Uh last
month, we chased uh six uh illegal
Japanese uh Chinese actually Chinese
drift nets all the way from the Indian
Ocean back to China and turned them over
to the Chinese government with the
evidence of illegal activity. Uh we're
working in partnership with the Mexican
Navy to save the endangered bakita. And
uh yes, those are poor fishermen who are
going after this bakita, but they're
doing it illegally. So we seized 20 uh
25 long lines and about 42 illegally set
gil nets, and we confiscated those. Uh
you know, you you can't use uh poverty
as an excuse for this kind of lawb
breaking. Otherwise, it would be
certainly uh quite all right for people
to sell cocaine because they're poor.
It's certainly all right to rob banks
because they're poor. Uh so if you look
at the ocean as a bank that contains the
uh the savings or the investment for the
future of all humanity, then the
poachers are no different than bank
robbers.
Oh, and then on the question allow
reunion. Uh there are, you know, every
year uh the average number of people
killed by sharks is seven, which is
amazing when you consider that every day
about 300 million people go into the
ocean. So, you know, your chances of
getting killed by a shark are pretty
pretty small. In fact, it's more
dangerous to play golf. If you're out
golfing, your chances of being struck by
lightning or being stung by a bee and
dying are greater, and more people die
on golf courses every year than are
attacked by sharks. We need sharks. They
have shaped evolution in our ocean for
450 million years. They are an apex
predator and they're essential for the
ecological integrity of the ocean.
Therefore, there is no excuse for
killing them. The problem is is the
three places in the world where shark
attacks are more prevalent are
Queensland, Western Australia, and La
Union Island. And what do those three
places have in common? They have shark
kill programs. That is, they're
callulling sharks and funded by the
government to do that. Now, what does
that do? Sharks are territorial
creatures. Therefore, when you go in and
you kill sharks in an area, you create a
vacuum which draws more sharks into that
area. And those sharks are by nature
territorial and become very aggressive
as a jockey position within that
territory. Therefore, those programs in
La Reunion, Queensland and Western
Australia are creating aggressive sharks
and therefore the responsibility for the
shark attacks now becomes the people who
are killing the sharks. The government
of France in fact is contributing to
those shark attacks. And uh as for the
surfers who complain about this on our
advisory board, we are fortunate to have
Kelly Slater who's the probably the
foremost surfer in the world. And I
think Kelly's advice to the surfers
allow reunion was quite appropriate. He
said, uh if you're afraid of sharks,
then stay out of the ocean. You don't
belong there.
Do you think Greenpeace has enough power
to influence political decision in
Australia?
Greenpeace is a business just like the
World Wildlife Fund is. Um, they're
there to sell feel-good feelings. Join
Greenpeace. You're part of the solution.
You're not part of the problem. Last
year, Greenpeace brought in 375
million. They spent €170 million to get
that money. It's an investment for a
return. Um, you know, they have three
ships that do very little. Last year, C
Shepard brought in €12 million. We have
nine ships out there all the time. And
uh so we're doing more on less because
we realized a long time ago that money
is not the solution. It's the passion,
the imagination, and the courage of the
volunteers who are involved. So we spend
nothing on raising money. And the monies
that we do bring in, we spend on
programs and we accomplish more.
It is known that you're not on the same
page with Greenpeace, but some of your
supporters are both following Greenpeace
and you. They perhap you complimentary.
So, could you imagine a partnership or
will you always fight each other?
Well, first of all, we don't fight
Greenpeace, but we do fight attitudes.
When Greenpeace supports the seal hunt,
we oppose it. When Greenpeace supports
whaling, we oppose them. When Greenpeace
supports the killing of polar bears, we
oppose them. Uh they're not on the same
side. If you support the commercial
killing of seals, you're not on our
side. And uh so therefore, we're going
to challenge that. So, I'm not
challenging Greenpeace on the basis of
being Greenpeace. I'm challenging them
on the positions that that that they're
holding which we're against. That also
holds true to the World Wildlife Fund.
We work primarily with grassroots
organizations around the world. That's
where the strength of the environmental
conservation movement lies in that kind
of diversity. You know, there are about
3 million non uh government
environmental organizations registered
throughout the world. And that is the
strength of the entire movement. Not the
big organizations, but all of these
small organizations. They're the ones
that making the difference. They're not
the ones with the money. They're the
ones with the passion and those are the
ones that we we work in alliance with.
What is your feeling about the young
generation? Do you think they care about
the situation that they understand or on
the contrary that they gave up?
Well, there's a lot of all of that. Uh
younger people are certainly far more
aware today than than 20, 30, 40 years
ago. I mean, back in 1972, nobody even
knew what the word ecology meant. uh and
certainly people were blind to the real
problems. So I think young people are
far more aware now. Uh are they
involved? Yes, people are distracted by
everything from video games to
entertainment or whatever. But I do see
a level of involvement probably greater
than any time in in previous history.
And uh young people actually face a very
uh uh daunting challenge that uh other
generations before them didn't have to
deal with. And that challenges the fact
that this might not be a livable planet
at the end of this century and that's
going to severely affect uh you know
their life. So uh the the the obstacles
are very real and sometimes they're
quite overwhelming. I happen to believe
that uh when you face an impossible
situation and overwhelming odds you have
to find impossible solutions and I
believe those solutions can be found
again through imagination, passion and
courage and I'm seeing more and more of
that in in young people. We have nine
ships. On those ships right now, we have
about 125 volunteers from 20 or 25
different nations. It it all depends.
And so we have thousands of people who
want to participate. So there's
certainly I'm seeing the passion of
people who wanting to who want to get
involved. And they want to get involved
because when they join our vessels, they
can actually get the satisfaction of
seeing results for their efforts. they
go down, they shut down a illegal
fishing operation or they save x number
of whales or they save x number of
turtles on the beaches in say Costa
Rica. Uh these are real results and
therefore it gives people not only the
satisfaction of doing it but also the
encouragement that they can do more
because I believe that uh everybody has
the u the ability to to change things to
change the world and that we encourage
that individual initiative that
individual uh an individual imagination
to find those solutions.
Do people on board pay for it? No, no,
no,
no. Uh they come on board, they're
provided with a room and board and uh
there's they don't have to pay to join.
No. The only payment, I guess, is
whatever their air ticket is to to join
the the ship wherever it is in the
world. If it's in Australia, you have to
fly to Australia. If it's in Africa,
they have to fly to Africa. But there's
actually no um cost involved. In fact,
we don't even have a membership within
Sea Shepard. It's um we have supporters,
but we don't have a set membership.
Which could be your advice for the young
generation?
Well, my advice is really for people to
follow their passions and to uh you
know, if they're interested in something
to to pursue it. Uh you know, I find
that one person champion one cause makes
a difference. Uh because of Diane FSY,
mountain gorillas are survived in
Rwanda. Uh the work of Jane Goodall and
Bruty Delta when she's protecting
orangutans uh in Indonesia. Uh these are
examples of individuals who make a
difference because of their passion. uh
one man in um Bermuda, David Windgate,
because of him, the Bermuda storm petrol
didn't go extinct. I mean, I can't think
of anything more uh you know, a greater
legacy to leave than the fact that you
lived in an entire species was uh
prevented from going extinct. And so I
encourage people all over the world when
they come to me and they say, "Well, I'm
really concerned about, you know, say
protecting jaguars in uh in BISE." I
said, "Well, then then do that. You you
know, do whatever you can. use your
imagination and and and find ways to get
involved and do things like that. So
this is what we try to do is encourage
people to follow their own passions.
Soon there will be a presidential
election in the US uh for you who could
be the best candidate to defend green
issues.
There isn't one. There isn't one. That's
like trying to choose between, you know,
uh color and smallox. Really? There is
no best candidate.
Who could be the worst? the worst.
Oh, well, you got a choice between an
idiot, Donald Trump or a psychopath like
Hillary Clinton. I mean, that's
basically your choice. Uh, the problem
is that the United States is not a
democracy. It's an oligarchy and they
already choose the president before
anybody anybody gets to vote. I
personally was backing Bernie Sanders
and I believe that he he would have won
if they didn't rig the election against
him. And also the media refused to cover
them because the media is controlled by
the same people who control the
corporations who decide who's going to
be president. And uh so you're not going
to really get any democratic uh
representation in a country where the
corporations have the final say. And
that's pretty much true of everything.
For instance, um Justin Trudeau came to
uh uh Paris one month after being
elected as prime minister.
Justin Trudeau from Canada.
Yeah. One month after being elected as
prime minister of Canada, he came to
Paris and he was all gung-ho. He's going
to really do something about climate
change. I mean he's very idealistic and
he brought in about 150 people with him
and they all sat down and they were very
very serious and then he went home but
he had only been prime minister for a
month. So when he went home the people
who really control things must have sat
him down and talk to him because now
he's he's supporting the pipeline. He's
supporting the tar sands project. He's
uh saying that the fires that they had
in Alberta are not connected with
climate change. So he's becoming like
everybody else. It's basically because
they're just puppets who are told what
to do. They're not. We don't have any
world leaders. We basically have puppets
controlled by the corporations who
actually control everything. The
minoring companies, the logging
companies, the big fishing companies,
the nuclear power countries, they're the
ones that control everything. And the
the this so-called voting is just is
just a charade. You're not going to
that's why we never get anybody who
actually does anything. There is a
report, a petition on the internet
against you because you have Bridget
Bardau as a Facebook friend. What do you
answer to them?
I don't I don't have any politics. I'm
neither right nor left. I actually find
it quite funny that the the right
accuses me of being a leftist. The
leftist the left accuses me of being
right-wing. Uh I don't have politics. I
believe that the protection of our ocean
is what everyone has in common.
regardless of your religion, regardless
of your politics, regardless of who or
where you are, we all have that common
interest that we have to protect our
ocean. So, I'm not really concerned
about these anthropocentric concepts,
which you know, which is what politics
and religion are all about. They're
anthropocentric concepts. What we've
done over the last few thousand years is
set up this uh system where we have
declared ourselves to be the supreme
beings, almost like gods in our own
minds, and that nothing else matters.
We're in charge of everything. We're
more important than everything. I don't
believe that. We're not more important
than anything. In fact, worms and trees
and bees are more important than we are
because they can live without us. We
can't live without them. That makes them
more important than we are. So, I don't
get involved with politics. All I do
know with Bridget Bardau is that for
three years, we were trying to make the
world pay attention to the slaughter of
seals in Eastern Canada. Nobody paid
attention. And that's when I learned a
lesson. If you want to get people's
attention, you have to play the rule by
the rules that the media sets. And the
media only understands four things: sex,
scandal, violence, and celebrity. So, if
you want a story, you have to
incorporate those elements into the
story. So,
which is why some people say you are
sexist.
Well, personally, I don't really care
what they think. I'm not here to cater
to them. My clients are whales and
turtles and seals and sharks and birds,
and I couldn't give a about what
people think about me. I'm not here
representing them.
Do you trust people? No, I don't. Not at
all. Uh, but the thing is is that when I
Tell me why.
Well, first of all, let me just finish
what I was saying about bringing
Sorry about that.
By bringing her out to the ice, we
guaranteed coverage around the world.
Her picture appeared on every magazine
and we accomplished more with her one
visit to the ice than we had
accomplished in three years of doing our
activism. So, that's when I realized
that we have to incorporate celebrities
because they are media. Uh,
it's a kind of hacking. It's a kind of
hack. Do you know what's a hacker?
Hacker. Yeah,
I guess you could say it. It's kind of
It's a kind of media hacking.
Kind of like media hacking, I suppose.
Uh, you know, six months ago, I wrote a
speech to be delivered to the Russian
government. They're not going to listen
to me. But what I wanted to do was to
get them to stop whale meat
transportations through uh the Arctic
through their waters. So, I wrote the
speech. I had Pamela Anderson go to
Russia and deliver the speech. They not
only listened to it, they gave her a
standing ovation and they acted on what
we asked them to do. Why? Because Pamela
Anderson is a form of media. And uh so
we use celebrities and they allow
themselves to be used as a form of
media. So that's why we uh we deal with
them. And I'm really not interested in
what the politics of those celebrities
are. I'm interested in the fact that
they are just like a television station
or a newspaper a means of delivering a
message. What is your opinion about
Putin?
He's just like another world leader. I
don't have any.
Is he a puppet?
They're Well, they're all puppets of
others, you know. Uh Putin's probably
less of a puppet based on, you know, the
fact that he's a dictator in of of
himself, but who knows who's pulling the
strings there. I don't know. Uh I do
know that uh no real change comes
through politics, whether whatever that
system of government is. uh they are all
indebted to um the economic status quo.
They're all into short-term investment
for short-term gain uh without very I
don't I I can't think of a single
political leader in the world who looks
forward 100 years from now and says
what's this world going to be like
because of what we're doing right now. I
don't know a single one of them that's
doing that.
What is your opinion about the no
growing? Well, you know, no species has
ever survived on this planet outside of
the three basic laws of ecology. The
first is the law of diversity. The
strength of an ecosystem is with
diversity within it. The second is the
law of interdependence that the species
within that ecosystem are dependent upon
each other. And the third is the law of
finite resources. There's a limit to
growth, a limit to uh carrying capacity.
What we humans are doing right now is
stealing the carrying capacity of other
species. They have to disappear to make
room for more and more of us. But what
that does is diminish interdependence
and diversity which can lead to a
collapse of the entire system.
And if it it's happen if if we going to
to live a collapse,
what's going on? What's what's will
happen?
What will happen in a collapse?
Civilization will cease to exist. We may
go extinct. It's quite simple. Uh
because we cannot survive without
oxygen. We cannot survive without food.
and we cannot survive without runaway
with runaway climate change. So we we
don't survive. That's really what the
final consequences are. The only way
we're going to survive is to learn to
live in harmony with all the other
citizen species on this planet. We we
have to uh appreciate and understand the
role that they play, the role that
whales play, the role that fish play,
the role that birds play. They all
contribute to this life support system.
We can't continue to act like we're the
only species that matter. What could you
tell us about the Kusta team? Let's
start with the captain and that what
about the youngest Tim?
I knew Jacqu Kustoau. I met him on many
occasions and uh I think that he was a
man ahead of his time. He certainly uh
contributed a great deal to the
worldwide education on uh on marine
ecosystems. Uh so as an educator, he was
quite uh he he really contributed a
great deal. and the youngest team.
Well, I don't get along with Jean
Michelle Kustoau, but uh with the uh
with the kids uh you know, the grandkids
and everything I get along quite well
with uh and have worked with them and
have spoken with them. I think that you
know there's a it's a family that is
symbolic of uh of oceanic awareness and
I'm really happy to see that they're
involved. You know, the whole family is
involved in one way or the other and
they do make a contribution. I I like
them. Have you seen the so-called the
seventh continent or great Pacific
garbet patch?
I know what you're talking about. I I
we've had a plastic campaign now for
years. It's called the Vortex Project.
Vortex.
And what we do is we have beach cleanups
around the world. Uh we collect tons and
tons of plastic from around the world
and send that in for recycling. We ship
it off to a central place to be
recycled. Uh last year we brought in 72
km 70 tons of of gil net from the
southern ocean and had that turned into
shoes. Um so we're we're also looking
for alternatives to plastic. Uh right
now we have a project to find
alternatives to plastic straw drinking
straws and uh we're also working with a
company in Samalo that uh is making
plastic out of seaweed so it's actually
biodegradable. Uh so it's a combination
of cleaning up plastic uh discouraging
the use of plastic and finding
alternatives to plastic. It's it's a big
project for C Shepard.
What is your feeling about Fukushima?
Well, Fukushima is something that people
don't really want to talk about because
I want to talk about
Yeah, I know. But but in general in
general, they don't want to talk about
it because there's no solutions to it.
Uh the Japanese are trying to cover up
the damage, but the damage is uh extreme
and it will continue to be extreme. uh
radioactive water is seeping into the
groundwater below to Tokyo. They're
dumping it into the ocean. Uh we're
seeing the effects of this in fish off
the coast of California and certainly in
Alaska. It's a major major uh tragedy
that's been downplayed by the world
media and uh so but the problem with it
is that how do you deal with it? Uh you
can't you can't really clean it up. But
what it does herald is uh the similar
situation happening in other places in
the world. Just this last week, uh, the
Diablo nuclear power plant was shut down
in California. And we've been trying to
get that shut down for years because it
actually straddles two fault lines, but
they built a nuclear reactor on a major
earthquake fault line, two major
earthquake fault lines. So, they shut
that down. How they're going to
dismantle it, I don't know. But the
realization is coming is that, you know,
these nuclear plants can cause some
very, very serious consequences. uh
anytime there's an act uh an accident
like Chernobyl or Fukushima and uh in
only just one generation really we've
had two almost three major nuclear
accidents and that doesn't bode well for
the future of nuclear power worldwide.
What do you think about French nuclear
politics?
I'm certainly opposed to nuclear power
plants. Uh there's you know and uh but
you know here's the problem really comes
to it is that you've got you've got 7.5
billion people. How do you provide
energy to that? Uh there's nuclear,
there's coal fired, there's oil, there's
there's windmills and everything. But
the problem is our entire population
worldwide depends on fossil fuels. Uh
you know people think that nuclear power
is clean. It isn't. It actually is very
intensive use of fossil fuels because to
make one uh ounce of of uh uranium you
need a thousand tons of pitch blend door
which means that you have to mine it,
you have to crush it, you have to
manufacture it, you have to transport
it. The amount of fossil fuels used in
the nuclear industry alone almost
exceeds that in used in oil and coal
fire generating plants. So it's not
clean energy. That's a fantasy that it's
clean energy. But um the problem really
is too much energy consumption by too
many people producing too many products
which are essentially of no use use at
all. Uh we we really have to cut down on
useless products. We have to find ways
of stopping human population growth in a
responsible manner.
It's it's a kind of multian theory.
Yes. But
what is your opinion about that? Well,
it is. I mean, but the population will
not grow beyond 12 mill 12 billion.
That's a limit because it'll crash
before then. It just isn't. The planet
simply cannot
sustain
sustain 12 billion people. It's not
going to happen. And that's going to
happen before the end of this century.
It's going to crash. And uh I'm
absolutely convinced about that. Now,
the solution
is complicated. But you know what what I
find really frustrating is when people
say, you know, intelligent people say,
"Well, I'm not going to have any
children because well, you know, I'm not
going to contribute to that problem."
But they they represent less than 3% of
the entire population, the people who
actually are aware enough to say that.
And uh I always say they're people
probably should have children because,
you know, otherwise we're just raising
generations and generations of people
who have absolutely no awareness at all.
In fact, I think they made a great movie
about it called Idiocracy, where 500
years from now, we live in a world of
stupid people. But the the thing is is
that there there are no easy solutions,
but solutions have to be found. And I
think that we also really have to
concentrate on uh lowering our levels of
consumption of materials. And uh instead
of third world nations trying to become
first world nations, first world nations
should be looking at lowering ourselves
to a lower level of consumption.
Are you are you aware about the so-cal
theory?
His name is peak oil. You know peak oil.
Peak oil. Yeah.
What is your opinion about it's a
theory? It's a what?
Well, there it's a finite resource. is
it's going to crash. And right now we're
already seeing uh utilization of
fracking and uh other technologies to
extract less and less of what's
available. And uh so the problem with
oil is it's a drug and uh our entire
civilization is dependent upon that
drug.
We are junkies.
We are oil junkies and like junkies,
we'll do anything to get it. And if that
means destroying the planet we live on
to get it, we're going to do it. And if
that means killing people in third world
nations, if it means destroying our
ocean, we're going to do it because
we're dependent upon that drug. I mean,
look at the wars that we're fighting
right now over it. By 2030, we'll be
probably in a major war over the
Antarctic continent because that's the
last untapped reserve of not just oil,
but also cobalt and and uh other other
coal, for instance, 200 meter seams of
coal going through the Trans Antarctic
Mountains. It's untouched right now, but
they'll go for it. And when they do,
you're going to see major uh military
adventures in Antarctica. So the wars of
the 20th the 21st century will be wars
over resources and not just you know oil
but also water. We're going to have some
very serious uh conflicts over water
availability.
So in a certain way uh global warming
help uh big corporation to find oil in
uh Antarctica.
Oh yeah. Yeah. Well, it's going to make
it easier. It's making it easier to
exploit oil in the Arctic. It's also
going to open up fisheries. It's going
to open They see all of the benefits.
That's what they actually say. Well, you
know, you environmentalists, you see
that the glass is half empty. We see it
as half full. We see uh we see uh global
warming as something that is going to
help us economically. And that might be
so for a brief period of time, but it's
going to destroy us ecologically. I
mean, yesterday, uh the temperature in
Thran was 165° Fahrenheit. That's where
72 degrees C. I mean, who can live in in
in that kind of a situation, you know,
and uh we're seeing evidence of global
warming around us all the time or of
climate change and yet still the major
mainstream media is denying that it's a
real problem. It is a real problem. It's
going to be increasingly more of a
problem. Do you think the public opinion
would change its mind about green issues
if we were able to present an ecological
plan which would be economically viable?
Well, which make money? And then do you
think media would help to promote this
plan?
Well, certainly people would embrace um
uh ideas which are presenting
alternatives that are going to make
money for people. But also you have
those suppression of those ideas by oil
companies and other companies which uh
see these as barriers to their own
particular profits. So it's uh not that
easy just to find those alternatives and
promote them. Uh I mean there's been
many things that have been put forward
as alternative energies and uh less
environmentally harmful ideas but
they've been suppressed by the companies
that uh that are actually making profits
and they feel that those is a threat to
their profits. Not they are not juicy.
They are just blocked by uh the the oil
lobby.
Many of them are. Yes. Yes.
I know it's far away from your subject,
but I I would like to to have your point
of view about uh Arabi Saudis as we call
it in in French, you know, Saudi Arabia.
Saudi Arabia. What about it?
Yeah. Tell me tell me what is your point
of view about this country?
Well, I I I it seems to me there's an
incredible hypocrisy in that for
instance, the United States uh is
condemning um Islamic uh practices in
Syria, Iran and uh very Afghanistan but
embraces Saudi Arabia and the only
reason they do that of course is because
for money uh because Saudi Arabia is an
economic partner. So in because they
share the same economic views, anything
is anything is justified. But um I
believe personally I believe that one of
the problems in our our world today uh
are anthropocentric religions and all of
them. And so I think uh the world would
be a far better place if we abolished
Islam, Christianity, Judaism and all
those other religions that say that
human beings are the center of creation,
the center of universe and the all
powerful divine legends that we think we
are. Uh we have to put an end to that
and uh is that possible? I don't know.
But I do know that uh that is a root to
a lot of the violence and destruction uh
on this planet.
What is your point of view about Krishna
Morti?
Krishna Morty. I actually read uh the
life story of Christian Merty and I
remember one time where Christian Merty
in the 1920s actually held a press
conference where he said look uh there's
nothing special about me. I don't have
the answers. Uh this is basically a
hoax. And you know what happened? He got
more followers than ever. And that's
when he said okay whatever. I will be
what you want me to be. But he realized
the whole thing actually made no sense
at all. There are no gurus. There are no
priests. There are nobody there's no
people who have special answers.
Yeah. I have a question on boycott
because since you said that the
everything is about economics and
boycott is a is an economic weapon
because people can have an impact on the
economy. Uh do you advocate um boycott?
Well, yes and no. I mean the problem
with boycots are they're they're very
difficult to uh organize, very expensive
to organize and um also it's hard to
stop them once they start. Uh but uh it
is a valid economic uh weapon. Yeah,
there's no doubt about that at all. I
mean, the first boycott I ever
participated in was with Caesar
Shabbaz's uh boycott of California
grapes uh back in the in the 1960s,
which I found to be was quite effective,
you know, in order to get uh rights for
the farm workers uh in California. And
uh so Caesar Chavez did achieve quite a
bit through uh the boycotting of of
grapes. And uh so that was my my first
experience with the effectiveness of
boycotts.
There is an increasing number of people
that have chosen to be vegetarian,
flexi, vegetarian or vegan. Many of them
change their way of eating and living
because of sanitarian and ethical
scandals. Do you think that changing our
eating habits helps to fight for saving
the planet and its biodiversity?
I absolutely do believe that. Uh my
ships have been vegan vessels since 2000
and vegetarian vessels since 1980 and uh
because I believe that we have to set an
example that uh we can't save the world
by being part of the problem. Uh 40% of
all of the fish taken out of the ocean
is fed to pigs and chickens and uh
farm-raised salmon. When you eat a
hamburger, you're actually eating a
fish. Uh so we're literally eating the
oceans alive. We're killing 65 billion
animals every year uh on factory farms
around the world. Uh we're feeding more
uh fish to, you know, for instance to
our chickens and are being eaten by
alpatrosses and and puffins. Uh pigs are
eating more fish than all the seals in
the North Atlantic. I mean, this is just
completely unnatural behavior. And I do
believe that uh the humanity can sustain
itself quite uh healthily on plant-based
diets. uh they produce uh use less
water, produce less greenhouse gases,
are uh less of a source of pollution
than uh than animal products. So yeah,
that we we very much uh promote that,
but we do it for environmental reasons.
Uh we're not, you know, there there's
many ways that people promote veganism
is ethical or for their health. Uh but
we do it for environmental reasons.
Do you think insects would be part of
the solution? Well, we you know I I I
know I've been at Africa and I've seen
it's been a long time. I mean they eat
flies on Lake Victoria. I mean they eat
grubs. I mean that's but I I I think we
have to understand that insects serve an
incredible uh incredibly important
purpose doing what they're doing. This
planet is sustained and kept healthy by
bacteria, plankton, and insects. Uh and
we need them doing what they're doing.
uh the bees making sure the that plants
are pollinated uh worms and ants and
that ariating the waters. They're
basically the custodians of the planet
and we need them to to to do that. Um I
don't say that that everybody in the
world is going to go vegetarian or vegan
whatever. I'm just saying that it
certainly is an alternative and
especially for first world nations where
there really isn't a necessity to be
eating steak and chickens and everything
every single day. Uh I mean, you know,
it's very difficult to to go when you go
to into any city to find a restaurant
where you can actually get a decent meal
now. But uh we're finding more and more
that there are becoming places where you
can do that and uh people are
discovering more and more that you can
sustain yourself quite healthily with on
a plant-based diet.
Do you think the delphinarium model as
the marinand where sea mammals are kept
in captivity is going to its end?
We've been working on closing down
dolphinariums for decades and we're
making a lot of progress and we're suing
marine land now in Antib but but we're
also uh uh working to uh shut them down
worldwide. Uh right now there's 65 no
excuse uh yeah there's 65 um orcas in
captivity. Uh 165 of them have died in
captivity. And so what we're working is
to uh to get those 65 that are still
there free and are we're advocating seps
to do it. It's really a form of slavery.
And it also it's just like when you know
they raided Africa and they killed
people and then took the survivors as
slaves. We're doing the same thing in
Japan. We kill hundreds and hundreds of
dolphins and we take the best ones and
and put them in dolphinarians to amuse
people. Uh they don't belong there.
These are extremely intelligent,
sensitive, uh, socially complex,
self-aware, sentient creatures, and we
should give them the respect that they
they they deserve. They're not here to
do silly tricks for human human beings
amusement.
The last question,
um, have you got some questions to ask
to us?
What is it that you're trying to um,
what kind of information you're trying
to get across? What kind of message are
you trying to get across?
We just try to make people talk to each
other.
Mhm.
That's it.
Well, that's certainly, you know, uh
encouraging dialogue on all of these
issues is uh is is important and we need
more people to make the to discuss these
things. Also, we need people to discuss
these things in a manner that isn't so
confrontational all all the time. Uh
people get very polarized on their on
their opinions. You know, if you have
hold this bit opinion, then you're
automatically don't like the people on
that opinion. Uh that's another problem
with human beings is that we have this
nationalism which springs from probably
primitive tribal impulses. I don't know.
I know a few years ago I got an insight
into this because uh we there's a
restaurant in the United States. There's
a big one called the medieval times and
you go there and you have a medieval
meal and you get to see knights jousting
and things like that and uh and you're
sitting there. They you don't have any
choice where they sit you. So it gets
sit in the blue section, the green
section, the black section, whatever.
And what I observed there is that they
sat us in the blue section. Within 20
minutes, everybody in the blue section
hated everybody in the green section.
Everybody in the green section didn't
like anybody in the red section as
they're cheering for their night. In
other words, what we saw there was
nationalism rising out of for no reason
at all. Why are you French? You were
born in France. Why are you American?
You were born in America. You know,
that's the only difference between
people. And so they go crazy over
colored pieces of cloth and uh different
ideologies which basically mean
absolutely nothing. All people are
exactly the same. And uh so this this I
think is going to along with religion
which of course is another form of
division is um going to be the downfall
of uh of humanity is all of these
divisions caused by artificial things
like nationalism and religion and that
basically it's all one big football game
and everybody's got a team and they're
cheering on the teams and eventually
they get into fights over it as we see
all the time.
Paul Watson, thank you.
Thank you.
[Music]